what is the top movie on my list though
the most perfect sci-fi movie as far as
I'm concerned the most perfect sci-fi
movie ever made as far as I'm concerned
now I'm going to say to you again there
are certain movies through the years
that I just think are genre defined
films Die Hard is a genre defining
action movie it completely flipped what
an action movie was and basically
everyone tried to copy ever since Lethal
Weapon is similar and basically the list
goes on but as a scii movie the most
perfect is the Predator Arnold
Schwarzenegger Carl Weathers even Jessie
Ventura are perfectly cast in this
film they're again not the greatest
actors in the world but they don't need
to